in health news now why don't women take
their birth control on time well more
than likely it's because you forget to
get your prescription filled
and it's the reason co-founder and ceo
sophia zahn started her company pandea
health
delivery of birth control to women
across the united states with up to a
year's supply depending on the
prescription
now she's always been able to ship to
all 50 states but only now can she and
other physicians within her company
prescribe throughout nevada as well as
half a dozen other states
she says it's about care convenience and
confidentiality
you can keep stuff confidential and you
just fill out a questionnaire
the same 20 questions i'd ask you if you
came into my office do you have liver
cancer do you have breast cancer
what medication are you on what works
for you what doesn't work
for you a self-reported blood pressure
so we need a blood pressure from the
past 364 days
you can call up your doctor's office or
whatever place you've been to
or if you have a cuff at home or the
pharmacy or the grocery or i like
fire stations she says there are 40
different birth control pills and if one
or two didn't work for you prior she
says she can definitely find the right
fit with the least amount of side
effects
she's personally written more than 2 000
birth control prescriptions over the
past two years
and prides herself on having the only
women founded women
and doctor-led telemedicine company for
this service